[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance the first perhaps the only
international organization of any kind
to congratulate Trump on his Muslim ban
in sheep's clothing was so-called
Islamic state Isis the terrorists it
sent him no bouquets it issued no press
releases it did not have to it has been
celebrating him and this plan which will
almost certainly instigate the deaths of
American citizens since the night of the
election it unlike so many of us
believed he would do what he said he
would do and it could not be happier
from BuzzFeed news Isis also sees trump
as an ideal enemy for propaganda
purposes the former and current members
of the group said believing that his
campaigns heated rhetoric about Muslims
will help the extremist group with
recruitment by reinforcing its central
narrative that America and the West are
at war with Islam of course Trump has
just done Islamic states work for it
what better recruitment tool could there
be
what better instigation to homegrown
terrorists throughout the world to rise
could there be
what better confirmation that all the
terrorists insane immoral
rationalizations for their bloodlust
could there be the United States of
America invoking exactly the kind of
action that Islamic state always said it
would an intelligent ten-year-old could
tell you could tell Trump that what he
enacted last Friday criticized by John
McCain and Lindsey Graham as a
recruitment tool for terrorists
criticized by the organization of the
infamous Koch brothers as the wrong
approach an intelligent ten-year-old
could tell you that the last thing the
new banana Republican government of the
United States would want to do if it
wanted to prevent radical Islamic
terrorism would be to ban Muslims simply
because they are Muslims since it was in
fact the first thing the new banana
Republican government of the United
States did do logic and simple common
sense offer only two possible
explanations since it is the greatest
possible gift to Isis for recruitment
for confirmation for rationalization for
instigating terrorist acts maybe here in
America it must either be that Trump
does not understand what will almost
inevitably follow or that he
does understand what will almost
inevitably follow why would an American
want that not an American president why
would any American deliberately do
anything to give terrorists a
rationalization to commit terrorism in
America we need look only to what
happened the last time a Republican
presidential administration and the
Republican Party were confronted by
large-scale terrorism here in 2001 for
time that administration grieved and
that party was solemn than that
administration was somber and that party
promised unity and both called for
bipartisanship and within a year the
Republicans were using 9/11 as a phony
pretext for war in Iraq and for bullying
dissenters and for creating an extra
level of bureaucracy with the dramatic
sounding invocation of the quote
homeland and running political
television advertisements against an
incumbent Democratic senator a triple
amputee Vietnam War vet named Max
Cleland television advertisements using
images of Saddam Hussein and Osama bin
Laden and outing the CIA operative
because her former ambassador husband
would not back up their lies to the
United Nations and manipulating
terrorists and color-code warnings when
and even the first Homeland Security
Secretary Tom Ridge later admitted this
is how he read it manipulating terrorism
arrests and warnings when political
fortunes turned against them and towards
the Democrats what was all that for was
it to make this country safer or was it
simply to make Republican possession of
the White House safer is there anybody
left who really thinks it was the former
and not the latter it is instructive
that one of the most chilling figures
from the Bush administration the Vice
President Dick Cheney condemned a Muslim
ban within hours of Trump first
proposing it in December 2015
it goes Cheney said then quote against
everything we stand for and believe in
even Cheney understood that while he
argued for stronger vetting of refugees
and immigrants still even Cheney
understood that Trump and the
anti-american loud surround him like
Buganda Barbie Conway and the Holocaust
diminishers Bannon and Priebus and the
spineless silent power mad Republicans
enabling him like Paul Ryan either do
not understand the implications the
instigations of what they have now done
either do not see how Isis can exploit
this or they do understand the
implications and instigations and the
ISIS exploitation it must be the one
thing or the other if it is the former
if none of them understand that Trump
has made this country seem as evil as
Isis tells its cult members we are the
none of them has the minimum
intelligence required to vote let alone
to lead a great nation but if it is the
latter and they do see the instigation
for what it is then they are prepared
for that outcome terrorism somewhere
blamed upon Trump now why would they
choose that why would you take an action
which itself forces you to take a second
action namely preparing for a terrorist
attack what happens next well what
happened before when large-scale
terrorism last presented itself the last
Republican administration exploited the
horror began to play with the fears of
285 million Americans to try to
consolidate its power here permanently
so a thought experiment if you will use
the past and what we know of Trump Trump
with less of a guiding moral force or
understanding of the value of each human
life than even Dick Cheney has what
would Trump do in the aftermath of a
kind of immediate genuine heart rending
tangible fear and sorrow that smothered
this nation last in 2001 would he like
george w bush rationalize a pointless
war somewhere unconnected to events
would he like george w bush seek to
blame democrats for a lack of
preparedness would he like george w bush
begin pushing back against freedom of
the press would he like george w bush
begin denouncing critics as terrorist
sympathizers would he like george w bush
try to make his reelection seemingly
guaranteed would he go beyond george w
bush and blame the judges who opposed
his illegal order would he go beyond
george
bush to make dissent and protest illegal
or impossible would he go beyond george
w bush and say I alone was right about
terror and Muslims and banning them and
henceforth my judgement should never be
questioned that as you ask yourself
those questions ask yourself one more
how many of those things has trump
already started to do resist peace